that's crazy man you got it
you know I plead the fifth it spoke yeah
police report and we placed our best
[Music]
start bench cut these New York
basketball duo's hello
so Katy and Kyrie Jason Kidd and Vince
Carter okay and mellow and Amar'e oh you
definitely got a star
Kyrie and KD got to New York all day
then you got a hit on with that and Milo
got into a mellow in and Ana Mari
kidding ya kidding kick-start bench cut
baseball football and basketball
basketball baseball then hey if I was
playing I will stop baseball all right
you can stop ball basketball bench
baseball baseball baseball a couple ball
kind of start fence cut these native
Brooklyn's people spike
Big E and M Jay can't do that that's
crazy
man you've got it you know I plead the
fifth
I can't do that one big you got it come
first tell me Dan you got a head on wood
up Dana smite that is Mike can't cut
spike though can't cuddle well just make
the bench back
dude start bench cut these dances that
are originated in Brooklyn the Milly
rock fish money dance and bone-breaking
cut the Bonebreaker
cut that I know a couple nights
this was due that's the dough button cut
you got to start this money I'm saying
and then you got a Bandstand Milly last
and Milly of course you got the wool
walk by Sosa everything that's wrong boy
Sosa Xbox one then you got my dance move
out you got a whole bounce with it I'm
saying and then you got what's that you
got the wool I like the one who got the
wool step by Mike deep throw me ask ya
it crazy they get crazy you show up to a
party you need to fight these three
songs right welcome to the party see
your and Gotti they got a B okay okay
hello okay okay you gotta start like
that okay then dad got a hit then with
that deal and then at the end you got a
you got a welcome to the party life yeah
Billy a pot smoke I just placed our best
cut go check out my music now whoa